has gum breasts my name is beautifu you
can hold your celebrations I'm not going
away forever just yay I'm just coming
away for another trip and I've decided
not to upload during this time because
my hair is just so goddamn awful
I look like Dimitri town trying to sell
sweatpants usually when I go away I
prepare videos in advance it's a lot of
work but we make it happen but this time
it just felt forced I don't want to put
quantity over quality never thought I
say that I feel so weird I feel so
quantity wins on YouTube that's like no
question look at leafyishere okay I'm
kidding
Calvin last year when I prepare for
scare PewDiePie I made so many videos in
advance because I knew what was going to
be away for a month and I really hated
that because I made videos that I didn't
like because I had to make them and just
wasn't fun and now I feel finally really
happy about the content that I'm making
and I want to stay too true to that so
no more [ __ ] content it's the funniest
joke of this video I haven't taken a
break like this from YouTube in probably
two years so it's a little scary you
don't know what's going to happen but
we're just going to have to go with it
if you will please be back because I
will be back as well thank you love you
guys so much I hope you guys understand
this decision it's just the way the it's
going to go from thank you for
understanding this decision the feedback
that I've been getting lately on the
channel has just been [ __ ] amazing
and I want to keep that up and I think
this is the best way to do it so I'll
see you in seven have a great time until
then and remember brushed stay awesome I
want a kpop haircut but I got sleazy
Russian instead you want to buy
sweatpants